salut j'ai seulement 5 secondes pour
vous rappeler que la dernière de mon
spectacle solidarité après qu'un appui
c'est le 11 décembre au zénith de paris
le lirez dans la description une bonne
vidéo
[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
d'une mystérieuse expédition en russie
qui a provoqué la mort de neuf
alpinistes dans de terribles conditions
on l'appelle la sphère du colza et
l'oeuf dans quelles conditions sont ils
morts pourquoi cette histoire suscitent
elles autant de curiosité
pourquoi le seul survivant n'at-il pas
pu raconter ce qui s'est passé plus
surprenant comment le dessin animé la
reine des neiges at il joué un rôle dans
la compréhension de cette histoire pour
percer ce mystère je serai accompagné de
mammites wing qui parraine ce sixième
épisode bonjour fabien merci beaucoup
pour l'invitation je suis très heureux
d'être à tes côtés pour cette
mystérieuse histoire
bienvenue dans cabinet curieux
[Musique]
nous sommes le 27 janvier 1959 au nord
de l'oural une chaîne de montagnes en
russie dix alpinistes expérimentés
démarre une expédition périlleuse de 320
km leur but atteindre l'autoroute n une
autre montagne et revenir en raison de
douleurs articulaires laurie lourdines
un des explorateurs doit rebrousser
chemin c'est ce qu'il l'a épargné du
triste sort de ses coéquipiers et qui
fera de lui le seul survivant de cette
histoire le groupe ne compte alors plus
que neuf personnes le 1er février
l'équipe commence à parcourir un col
mais s'arrête campé en effet des
conditions météorologiques sont très
mauvaises et il est trop difficile de
continuer la route n'est pas praticable
elle est même classé en catégorie 3 la
plus dure le meneur du groupe ihg hors
dia clough était censé envoyer un
télégramme deux semaines après le départ
pour confirmer son retour à son club
sportif mais jusque là aucun télégramme
un mois après le départ de l'expédition
une équipe de secours est dépêché sur
place puisque on est sans nouvelle des
neuf alpinistes mais à leur arrivée sur
place les sauveteurs tombe sur un camp
complètement abandonné quelque chose
attise leur curiosité l'attend est
complètement déchiré à un endroit et
pire encore tous les objets des
alpinistes figure sur place c'est comme
si les neuf alpinistes avaient été
réveillés en pleine nuit et avaient dû
subitement quitté leur camp sans même
prendre le temps d'enfiler leurs
chaussures mais réveillé par quoi on y
reviendra un peu plus tard rapidement la
chance sourit aux secouristes puisqu'il
retrouve des traces de pas dans la neige
mais au bout de quelques centaines de
mètres cette race s'efface complètement
en effet il commence à regarder partout
autour d'eux à la recherche d'éléments
qui pourraient avoir leur importance et
tout à coup sûr un grand pin c'est le
drame deux corps sont retrouvés ceux des
randonneurs ils ne sont vêtus que de
sous vêtements la tragédie continue
puisqu'on en trouve deux autres encore
un autre et on pourrait s'attendre à ce
que les quatre derniers ne soient pas
loin mais il reste étrangement
introuvable il faudra deux mois
supplémentaires pour retrouver les
derniers dans un ravin un kilomètre et
demi du campement étonnamment ils sont
vêtus contrairement aux autres ils
portent justement les vêtements des
autres alpinistes
on pourrait croire à un triste accident
mais quelques éléments viennent
perturber les enquêteurs
certaines victimes ont les côtes brisées
d'hôtes ont même la langue arraché et
certains ont les orbites vides plus
mystérieux encore on retrouve sur les
vêtements des victimes de la
radioactivité
la mort des neuf alpinistes reste donc
nimbé de mystère mais une question reste
en suspens pourquoi seulement quatre
victimes sur le groupe ont été retrouvés
avec de telles traces de violence et au
final que s'est il vraiment passé bonne
question difficile de se contenter d'une
explication météorologiques pour les
familles forces naturelles inconnu c'est
ce qu'ont finalement conclu les
enquêteurs sur leur rapport c'est
l'occasion pour beaucoup de curieux d'en
faire toute une montagne et de déballer
toutes sortes de théories loufoques
comme un appel des extraterrestres ou
une attaque de idy et si en réalité il
s'agissait de l'attak d'un peuple plus
précisément le peuple monde si une
ethnie locale de chasseurs nomades qui
vit sur la montagne ce peuple aurait pu
s'attaquer à eux pour différentes
raisons par exemple pour les punir de
leur intrusion sur la montagne sacrée il
s'avère cependant que ce peuple vivait
bien trop loin du lieu du drame la
théorie ne semble pas très plausible
alors si c'est pas une avalanche ni une
attaque ni un phénomène surnaturel
qu'est ce que c'est et bien une nouvelle
piste est apparu
cinquante ans la sphère du col de
l'offre va rester non résolus jusqu'en
2019 ou des journalistes et enquêteurs
se penchent à nouveau sur le fait divers
une théorie jusqu'à présent écartée et
pourtant raisonnable professur face
johan comme de l'école polytechnique
fédérale de lausanne et alexander plus
serein de l'école polytechnique fédérale
de zurich
deux spécialistes en la matière se
penche sur la théorie de l'avalanche
pour eux il est clair qu'il s'agit d'une
avalanche qui serait à l'origine de la
catastrophe
mais ce qui est étonnant et difficile à
comprendre c'est qu'un grand laps de
temps s'est écoulé entre le moment où
les neuf alpinistes ont installé leur
tente au sommet du col et le moment où
l'avalanche se serait déclenchée
en effet c'est curieux mais pour les
spécialistes il est tout à fait possible
que l'avalanche ne soit pas instantané
ils ont d'ailleurs démontré dans une
étude qu'une avalanche pouvait se
déclencher plusieurs heures après un
tremblement de terre il explique que le
passage des aventuriers sur le col
l'installation du campement sur une
couche de neige fragile et le vent
catabatique levante descendent des
pentes pourrait provoquer une avalanche
en déplaçant de grandes quantités de
neige ce qui explique le délai à un
moment précis une dalle de neige aurait
cédé car la charge de suez était trop
importante vous allez me dire oui mais
ça n'explique pas les violences
blessures des aventuriers un crâne brisé
une langue et des yeux arrachés ça fait
quand même un petit peu suspect oui un
peu mais c'est sans compter sur
l'intervention de la reine des neiges
qui a délivré si vous pouvez me
permettre ce jeu de mots un fait
intéressant en demandant de l'aide aux
studios disney et en faisant appel aux
personnes qui ont travaillé sur les
animations du film ils peuvent ainsi
simuler l'avalanche qui se serait
déclenchée ce soir là aucune dette
l'oeuf et simuler l'impact de blocs de
neige sur les corps humain les
chercheurs ont également fait appel à
general motors et ont recueilli les
données de plus de 200 crash test de suv
ils ont ainsi pu simuler l'impact d'une
dalle de neige
sur un corps humain et les potentiels
lésions créé au crâne et aux côtes
néanmoins beaucoup de personnes et de
scientifiques restent sceptiques quant à
cette explication d'avalanche certains
jugent que la pente où était installé le
campement était trop raide pour
provoquer une avalanche et surtout que
les blessures étaient trop violente pour
jim mc ewen le spécialiste des jets au
risque à l'université de durham au
royaume uni pour pouvoir provoquer de
telles blessures les blocs devraient
être extrêmement dur et se déplacer à
très grande vitesse au final la cause de
la catastrophe semble donc bien plus
raisonnable que toutes les théories
énuméré jusqu'à présent le groupe aurait
été surpris par une avalanche il aurait
déchiré la tente pour s'extirper de leur
tombeau et les personnes les moins
blessé aurait aidé leurs compagnons pour
sortir de là et partir en toute vie en
contrebas pour rejoindre des arbres pris
de panique les alpinistes n'aurait même
pas eu le temps d'enfiler leurs
chaussures et se répartit en pleine nuit
trouver un abri six d'entre eux seraient
morts d'hypothermie et les trois autres
auraient succombé à leurs blessures
concernant le fait qu'on n'ait retrouvé
certaines victimes entièrement dénudé il
ya une théorie qui peut expliquer cela
il s'agit de la théorie du déshabillage
paradoxal c'est un phénomène qui peut se
produire lorsqu'un être humain et en
hypothermie sévère voire mortelles à ce
moment là on ressentirait comme une
immense vague de chaleur qui se répand
dans notre corps et on aurait envie de
se déshabiller alors qu'évidemment c'est
la chose à ne pas faire pour ce qui est
des corps retrouvés avec le crâne ou les
côtes brisées il s'agirait des dégâts
dus aux blocs de glace charriées par
l'avalanche et concernant la langue
arrachés ou les orbites vides il y a
deux théories la première celle de
vautours qui serait simplement venu
manger les dépouilles et l'autre le fait
que certains corps et été retrouvé face
contre terre dans un petit ruisseau et
ce serait lui qui aurait causé la
nécrose de ces partis pour terminer au
sujet de la radio qui été retrouvées sur
les vêtements des victimes et bien il y
à la théorie du thorium le thorium est
un combustible radioactif qui étaient
utilisés à l'époque dans les lampes
quand vous l'aurez compris la sphère du
colza de l'offre reste aujourd'hui
encore nimbé de mystère bien que la
théorie de l'avalanche soit l'hypothèse
la plus probable
il ne s'agit que d'une hypothèse et pour
finir les amis une petite anecdote vous
l'aurez peut-être deviné mais le col a
été surnommé colgate l'oeuf en hommage
au leader du groupe des neuf alpinistes
qui se surnommait igor dyachkov
[Musique]
j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu
partagé nous en commentaire des idées de
sujets que vous voudriez voir dans
cabinet curieuse et peut-être on en fera
l'un des prochains épisodes merci
beaucoup à mamie twink d'avoir participé
et parrainé ce sixième épisode si vous
êtes friands de faits insolites et
méconnu je vous recommande vivement sa
série histoires de guerre sur sa chaîne
je vous mets bien sur un lien dans la
description merci beaucoup fabien pour
l'invitation dans son émission ça a été
un plaisir pour moi d'être à tes côtés
pour raconter cette mystérieuse histoire
j'espère te retrouver très prochainement
pour une nouvelle vidéo et je vous dis à
très bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
avec grand plaisir si vous ne connaissez
pas moi je m'appelle toujours fabien
olicard merci à vous qu'il ait fait
cette vidéo vous pouvez vous abonner à
cette chaîne c'est gratuit si vous le
souhaitez activer la cloche vous pouvez
aussi me retrouver sur scène c'est la
fin de mon spectacle il reste moins de
dix dates en tournée dans toute la
france et la grande dernière au zénith
de paris le 11 décembre je vous mets
également dans la description le lien
vers les 5 premiers épisodes de cabinet
curieuse déjà parus et je vous mettrais
également un lien vers mon magazine
curieuse c'est pas un hasard comme ça
vous pourrez le découvrir directement
sur le site internet prenez soin de vous
à très bientôt ciao
alors ils sont où ces extraterrestres
[Musique]
tous